team Trump just hitting back of the
Department of Justice's attempt to
muzzle what he can say in public about
the 2020 election case the Department of
Justice wants to prevent Trump from
sharing details about their
investigation but as lawyers say it
would violate Trump's First Amendment
rights quote in a trial about First
Amendment rights the government seeks to
restrict First Amendment rights worse it
does so against its administration's
primary political opponent during an
election season in which the
administration prominent party members
and media allies have campaigned on the
indictment and proliferated its false
allegations
the former president ripping apart the
Justice Department's charges this
weekend watch whenever more Biden
corruption is exposed his henchmen
charged me with crimes now I'm being
indicted for you I'm being indicted
because of what we've done and I'm being
indicted because they're afraid of all
of us because we have a movement that's
never been seen in the history of our
country those indictments aren't worth
the paper they're written on they're not
worth they took away free speech and as
the Democrats of the media go hard on
Trump you can probably guess who's
getting a pass
this Focus this Obsession I would say on
Hunter Biden is really just a Whopper of
what about ISM because the Republicans
are trying to deflect to diminish to
defend uh Donald Trump we're going to
have a campaign that is going to be
filled with a lot of what about isms we
know the Republicans are going to talk
about Hunter Biden a lot we know that
there is a lot of
um
you know the influence in Washington
that's based on people's family
connections last names matter a lot on K
Street you will know as you were very
cautious about starting impeachment
proceedings this is frivolous this is a
diversionary tactic
I heard before Junior you're a lawyer
so if
the Department of Justice says you know
you're not allowed to talk about this
case for the next year in the middle of
a presidential campaign how is that not
illegal
well it may be what you're saying is
unconstitutional you can't strip him of
a right to say any American have a right
to say I'm innocent of these charges
here's why I'm innocent of these charges
uh and I would imagine that the court is
going to allow him to be able to go out
wherever he wants because I thought his
I don't always agree with his lawyers I
think sometimes they've been maybe C or
derate but I thought whomever wrote that
was pretty good because he made clear
you can't deny an American the
opportunity particularly the other side
is talking about it as well where I
disagree with his lawyers any if
president Trump former president Trump
attacks the court or the prosecutor
again he should have he should have
something tamped on him around that but
professing his innocence laying out the
facts as he knows it laying out the
evidence as he's going to present it on
his side what do you mean when you say
attack what does that mean when you say
that the judge is an idiot when you say
that the the prosecution is a henchman
these are things that it will inflame
and and not serve anyone's interests did
he say the judge was an idiot I haven't
heard that he may have but
but I think he should be able to say
whatever he wants regarding the facts
and the evidence in the case so he could
say the judge was a partner at Hunter's
Law Firm the same firm that did the
dossier and has donated about 4 300 to
Barack Obama Joe Biden you can say that
you just can't say she's an idiot right
but but there's nothing wrong but I
would imagine if someone accused me of
the things they accuse the president of
I would be saying I didn't do those I
wouldn't be personalizing with the judge
but that's his he has every right to do
that but he does not have a right to do
is to attack the court and to attack uh
the prosecutor personally if you want to
attack their case I think he's fully
should be fully protected okay so what
if the in Discovery the Department of
Justice hands us stuff to his defense
attorney and it said we had agents
crawling all over January 6. Trump can't
say that during an election campaign I
think he's going to say what he wants
given his history I think he will not be
uh taking things back when he's trying
to run for president and has all these
indictments I'm not surprised that the
Department of Justice would like him to
say less they don't have any credibility
when it comes to the repeated things
they've tried to bring against him and
they're really hoping now that one of
these indictment sticks on the j6 thing
you know to answer the question about
why he would go after the players here
including the judge or the prosecutor
it's because we've seen since Trump
entered the political Arena 2015-2016
that the people who were investigating
him had political motive Peter Schrock
Lisa Page at the FBI investigating him
saying he could never be president now
you have this judge in D.C on the j6
case who is an activist she has donated
lots of money to Democrats she was very
sympathetic to the BLM riots while she's
throwing j6ers Behind Bars longer than
prosecutors even asked for so that is
relevant to the context of the broader
situation people to understand why he
may have some commentary on that but
while this is all happening with the
indictments and this is the double
standard play Hunter Biden is rewriting
his plea agreement he was able to to
plead guilty when he was supposed to
plead not guilty and now he's working
with doj to figure out what's next after
they screwed up in front of the judge
and got caught with their blanket
immunity statement so while Trump is
dealing with all this Hunter Biden is
working with doj on another sweetheart
deal that may also fall apart depending
on what's in it and the lawyer for the
former president Trump said this weekend
we should have cameras in the courtroom
this can't be a secret trial right
before an election Dana so I've had a
long-standing principle in my life I am
against cameras in the courtroom full
stop like I agree on the on the federal
level I think they've held there's never
been cameras allowed in the in the
courtroom in the federal level I think
it just adds to chaos chicanery nonsense
chicanery you have you know and actually
you ask the um press secretary to Bill
Clinton whose name was Mike McCurry
McCurry thank you um sorry Mike
Democratic trivia right here yeah thank
you
um he was the first to allow cameras in
the briefing room how do you think
that's gone yeah in the briefing room
when you have okay yes and like making
like a mockery of it one of the things
that the Supreme Court did during covid
was they allowed under a bit of duress
but it seemed to work out kind of okay
was you could listen to the audio I like
that and the audio actually makes you
listen
um the other thing is if you're watching
it and you're you have cable news
pundits like commenting on it and
watching like you might get for either
side you're on the legal Nuance is wrong
you might get it wrong so I think
cameras in the courtroom are not a good
idea for the long run and I wouldn't do
it in this case either okay I would do
audio in this case only Greg Gutfeld
your thoughts on this gag order attempt
or whatever they're calling it here with
the president oh well it appears that
they want to limit Trump's public
comments isn't that the whole point of
the trial so they're trying to limit his
public comments maybe they should limit
his comments about the comments they
want to limit about the comments that
they want to limit about
as for Nancy Pelosi saying this is a
waste of time the Biden impeachment
thing you want to know what a waste of
time was that think about that first
impeachment over a phone call it wasn't
just a waste of time it was about when
that waste of time took place that was
during the hearings for covid that was
in that period of time when we should
have been looking at that instead we
were looking at this because the media
felt that fighting Trump was more
important than fighting this weird
strange disease that's coming out and
killing a bunch of people so now they
lowered the bar they got a drink at it
that's the way I say it so we've got to
have you know they they missed the good
old days when there wasn't anybody
fighting Pac the good and bad part about
Trump is there's no off switch so you're
going to have it no matter what can I
mention one thing about this which is if
doj is going to ask for this protective
order and the judge is going to say yeah
Trump you better respond to this she
should also issue a warning I think to
the justice department that if any of
this leaks like the other leagues then
there should be consequences for the
prosecution as well 100 percent agree
with Dana because they will be leaking
but Jesse just one thing on the judge is
giving money to campaigns that happens
on both sides this is not this is I just
want to make clear
incredible but they're a lot right but a
lot of Judges Democrat and Republicans
but the history of doj with Trump does
not bode well for that context is what
my point is well if he does get the gag
order I'm sure he'll violate it
immediately
he will and he'll dare the judge to do
something about it up next the liberal
media has a defense for Kamala if you if
you dare criticize her you're a racist I
want to Brian kill Mead I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now